dans ce supermarché les recommandations
sont plutôt suivi le masque sur le nez
la majorité des clients n'a pas attendu
les nouvelles annonces du chef de l'état
pour le porter de toute façon on aurait
dû les mecs tout le tort on l'aimé tout
le temps faut pas là il attend le
premier route pour que ça soit mis dans
les magasins fait inadmissible face à un
certain relâchement dans le respect des
gestes barrières les médecins alertent
pourtant depuis des semaines brandissant
le risque d'une seconde vague
cette nouvelle règle saluée par les
soignants ne fait pas l'unanimité
l'obligation pour moi je suis
prisonnière prisonnière de mon physique
pressez pas obligatoire d'allonger le
choix de palme est c'est obligatoire oui
je la mettrais je ferai comme le
confinement je fais mes courses tout une
fois tous les quinze jours je ferai pas
d'autres magasins si je suis obligé
pourquoi attendre 15 jours pour imposer
cette loi
selon l'exécutif ce délai nécessaire
pour fixer le montant et les modalités
de l'amande et permettre aux
restaurateurs comme aux commerçants de
s'organiser
on mettra à l'entrée des agents de
sécurité qui demanderont aux clients
d'ing de porter le masque
s'ils veulent rentrer au super et on
ferait respecter centres commerciaux
salle de sport lieux de culte salle de
spectacle la liste des lieux publics
clos concerné n'est pas encore fixée
dans les cinémas ou le masque est
obligatoire que dans les lieux de
circulation
il pourrait le devenir durant les
séances on va faire des tours en salles
plus nombreux qu'à l'accoutumée
on compte aussi sur les autres
spectateurs pour faire un rappel au cas
où on s'en rend compte c'est quand même
très difficile quand on est dans le noir
un décret sera prochainement rédigé par
le ministère de la santé
certains magasins ont déjà pris les
devants comme cette enseigne qui le rend
obligatoire dès ce jeudi